and that will trickle out the center ice
o Ry played it off the boards following
up neita ryer stepped around him good
set up pass by Lowry toon the [Music]
SC that Lowry line goes to work again and the Jets
have the one- nothing lead the identity line the
grinder line another chance and it's off the rush
they're not going to dump the puck if they've got
a play to make and this is a great balance
of of size strength and skill this is just a
hey play good job from nether Rider recognizes
there space not a ton of it so he makes a nice
little pass Appleton stops backs it up yeah
good Puck movement there for sure as at the
line forsberg will carry it in neat move Philip
forsberg toad drag right in scores forsberg with
a beautiful play his third of the Year ties this
game at one wow 42 goals and just watch this one
a nice little move with some skill right there
to split the D and then watch his left foot or
his right foot part of me he protects the puck
with his PO from the PO check right there kick
the stick out of the way he drags it in behind his
body boy that's tough for Brad see he doesn't see
the release point because it comes from behind
his leading foot Shing at Center O'Reilly is
there also backing up Fabro Fabro former first
round pick 17th overall 2016 Puck loose in the
front of the net and then slides past shankley
he gets it back Mason Appleton his fourth goal
of the season open the scoring at 404 long we shot
through here's K denied by SOS that pu took a good
bounce for the Jets the Perry outworking his
mat there and put it right into the glove of
yussi [Applause] Saros Chi Deep by Conor carry a
g in front of him protected the puck but now it's
loose and Conor hops do it stops plays it down
for I four assists in St Louis Wednesday shyle
looking out for Corner [Applause] scores another
brilliant shift from the Jets first line and it's
2-1 [Music] wiip unspoken communication between
the two of them there you win a battle look at
that just a great commitment to being first to
the puck and then the Top Line the skill line
not a St to cycle it it's Conor toow and then
now you have everybody chasing that cycle pulls
everybody to the wall well something's got to open
up in the middle of the ice and this pierces the
slot the pass right onto the tape of Kyle Conor
great defensive structure they block a shot and
a good chance through the scene here's loong
following up can't do anything with it pass
ahead and on the left side with speed it's
Kyle Conor off the wing Conor right up front
scers what a goal by Kyle Conor and it's 3-1
Jets the win by me here as Mar shley in his
line come up the ice and this is great defense
there's number 55 that breaks the play up watch
where he takes this pass it's off a skate onto
his stick all in one motion and then he'll let
number 81 go to work and do the rest forehand
backhand and the puck and all the Defenders for
Nashville end up in the back of the net this is
a playoff of speed we showed you the goal before
the the off was knocked down he couldn't get the
puck through Sam Berg up at the hash marks good
Escape move pounded it back to the blue line he SP
with a shot rebound and Peretti can't shoot here's
aers with a drive and a good save by UC SOS Conor
and Mory for that to happen poke out by shearwood
for checking Mark shley sets it up conter with
a ripper and that get through Saros rolling pu
like a left turn luckily for SOS and the Predators
that missed the net for fetty staying with it sets
it up steered back to [__] Ley and he misplayed
it off es skap and it's collected there by nikist
ahead comes McCarron net Drive nikist Mike McCarr
right in and he just lifted that over the goal
Brasa may have gotten a piece shley into the Zone
the tight quarters got it through a set of skates
Conor to Peretti Conor back for shley shoots parer
City rebound and caught Peretti scores [Music]
[Applause] Cole Peretti with his second in as many
games and it's 41 use it streak and so does Cole
Peretti now with points in five straight games
this is fantastic after the entry was congested
shley finds a way to loosen the puck up look at
that rebound and petti has to elevate this Puck
and make it quick there's not a ton of net to
shoot at and he has to put it in the top Corner
that last go Peretti from sh shy and Conor second
career power play goal for Cole Peretti Connor and
shley each now have six points in their last not
even five periods there's a shot by forsberg and
he scores forsberg with a hot shot his second
makes it a two goal Jets lead insult to injury
this is a fouron four goal so the Predators will
still go to the power play and this is one that
Lauren bris would certainly like to have back this
shot from forsberg a snapper that goes 90 mil an
hour the puck went out obviously Baron is strong
up on the place two two sticks on the ice down
there one's broken in half NE P off this Scramble
Play Conor looking for smid in the corner now com
back near Conor at bounces to follow the rising
and that went up and out of play behind the goal
SOS is allowed four on 28 Shots tonight long pass
up ahead pretty good one thomasino the trailer
Yosi put it to the goal oh and BR is able to kick
that away he'll leave it Alex aalo catching up as
spau in the slot the shot rebound sh right there
and he goes down and that puck heads up behind
the goal he had a very physical game to see the
least Adam Lowry now Baron will Rumble off the
boards but it's being checked on the pl it's
pushed in deep Lowry Baron and Appleton right
now for Winnipeg jamelo pounds out behind the goal
Baron at the circle is Appleton Baron goes back to
the Blue Line Dello to Dylan shoots [Applause]
[Music] scores Brendon Dylan with his third goal
in the last three games and it's 52 wiip B Goen
interference there it is Goen interference third
line does what they do best let's get it out
of trouble from low to high and boy the puck
arrived I didn't see anybody in the blue paint is
the contact made in the crease so you're entitled
to the ice in front of the crease nothing in
the crease there's nothing even close so far
like ohy that's a fantastic play in be surprised
of this get another look yeah that that's that's
Adam Lowry's [Applause] ice after deliberation
with the referees we do have a goal on the ice
certainly your teammates appreciate that work
you're paying the price like that Saros as you see
back in the Nashville goal 349 remaining in this
one 52 Jets Del geel sends across ice and they
score Barry with a long range drive and it's 5 to
three face offs are so important secondary effort
to win that one back from McCaron and the shot
and watch thomasino to the left of your screen
as he steps into that shot Lane gets a tip on that
one and boy I'm sure that bris was not expecting
that to come it was going 5T there goes Dello
getting to that puck ahead forah following me
get it out fory going after shley put it off the
boards aollo trying to clear he does Conor oh he
look to chip it pass Yosi Conor he's got sightly
in front but he scores and gets the hattick Kyle
conter [Applause] and the fifth career
hattrick for number 81 high performance
part of the night so yes Conor with a
fourpoint night not going to miss that
one marle with four assists the Jets
will improve to 74 and two they've
won three in a row and they take this
one six to3 over the Predators it's all
over